the more the biden administration
becomes entangled in the southern border
the more progressive democrats are being
forced to confront images they publicly
condemned under the trump administration
first it was kids in cages and now it is
the wall
white house correspondent kevin cork is
taking a look for us tonight good
evening kevin
evening shannon battle lines as you can
well imagine have been drawn over major
league baseball's decision to move the
all-star game from atlanta to denver but
there's actually much more at play here
than just the mid-summer classic there
is a battle brewing over business
politics
and the intersection of culture and
sports
not since the broncos beat the falcons
in super bowl 33 as colorado enjoyed
such a victory over the state of georgia
snatching the major league baseball
all-star game and with it
an estimated 100 million dollar economic
boost
but it's how we got here that's led to
so much anger
politically speaking it's democrats who
are getting the credit or the blame
depending on your perspective
for sending the game packing and for
encouraging numerous companies
to target the state for condemnation
over its newly minted voter integrity
law
but as the saying goes one man's trash
is another man's treasure
and we're excited for this opportunity
we're honored to to accept this
opportunity on behalf of the colorado
rockies and the major league baseball
and experience for all coloradoans this
is a big deal
and we should celebrate as such there
are numerous key differences between
colorado and georgia voting law
for example in colorado an id includes
those printed by colleges and
universities utility bills
bank statements and pay stubs and all
registered voters in colorado
receive mail-in ballots automatically
republicans are
framing the move of the major league
baseball all-star game
as an affront to the american working
man and woman
tell you who's getting screwed it's the
little guy
it's a little work little guy that's a
working georgian either working in these
bars
taverns at hotels that now are not going
to have
guests because the all-star game and
major league baseball
made the decision to pull the game out
of here because they don't have enough
backbone to stand up
meanwhile near the u.s mexico border
heartbreak
images of a crying migrant child asking
border patrol officers for help
he'd been dumped near the rio grande
river a reflection
and consequence say critics of the white
house's failure or refusal to stop the
illegal migrant wave along the border
this is homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorkas
claims dhs quotes may restart
construction on the u.s mexico border
wall
to fill any gaps in the current barrier
former president donald trump
celebrating the possible pivot by the
biden administration
telling newsmax quote i think it's great
that they reverse themselves but a lot
of damage was done
by the way secretary mallorcas insisted
that there would be no more use of dod
funds to build the wall something as you
know the trump administration
did but do keep this in mind illegal
migrants are being housed at
dod facilities all over the country
at taxpayer expense shannon
all right kevin see you back here in
just a few minutes indeed thank you very
much